Well, let's take a look at a shawl collar
for a pullover. In these two examples,
the collar is really high and tight
and they look really uncomfortable.
Let's take a look at how we
can improve these collars.
Here's a typical shawl collar neck
opening. It's basically a V neck
with a straight bottom. In this example,
the bottom is four inches and the neck
opening is a typical eight inch.
Which would fit my mannequin. If I lay
a four-inch wide collar along this edge,
we can see that it comes up really
high up against the neckline.
If we fold the collar in half,
it's still pretty high.
That collar is filling in that eight inch
neck opening and making it more
like a four inch neck opening.
And I don't want a turtleneck.
By opening up the neck in this example,
four or five inches,
the angle changes and the folded
over collar will fit much better.
The lesson here is you can't use
a standard neck opening for a shawl
collar. You need to make it
wider so that collar will fit.
Here's another shawl collar variation,
the yellow collar is knit in 2x2,
ribbing in a very long, skinny strip.
It meets in the center front
when it's folded over the neck, it isn't
taking up as much space in the neckline.
That skinny band can also be overlapped
slightly in the front,
but you need to accommodate
that overlap in the neck opening.
Here's a wider collar knit in the other
direction, also in 2x2 ribbing,
it's been blocked heavily.
As in the previous drawings,
you can see that this collar fills
in that neck opening and comes up really
high at the neckline. ,ven folded over.
It's pretty high and tight.
Making the neck opening wider will give
the collar more room and it'll
be much more comfortable.
As machine knitters, we need to consider
our needlebed limitations.
This piece is 200 stitches wide
and it won't go around the neck opening.
I'd need to knit and seam to pieces
or knit this collar by hand.
There are many,
many variations of the shawl collar.
Look at this one closely and you can
see that it's knit in pieces.
The fronts are ribbed in one direction
and the back of the collar is
picked up, knit the other way.
And then it's seamed. This is a great
solution for our needle bed limitations.
Also, notice the front edges of this
example are shaped,
forming a nice deep collar up
at the neckline while maintaining
a fairly narrow flat V opening.